لقد ألمح الإيرانيون إليها
وكادوا يتهمونك بها بطريقة ما بالوقوف
وراء الهجوم الإرهابي على
العرض العسكري والمدنيين في أفار
خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع حيث قُتل العشرات من الأشخاص
بمن فيهم الأطفال ، ما
رأيك في
أنها تهمة سخيفة وأنها
اتهامات مضحكة
كذب فيها النظام الإيراني باستمرار بشأن الأشياء التي
واجهها النظام الإيراني في وضع صعب
للغاية داخليًا ، لقد استجابوا
عادةً بقوة وبوحشية ضد
شعبهم في كل مرة
لديهم مشكلة داخلية يحاولون توجيه
أصابع الاتهام إلى الآخرين الذين يتهموننا.
يتحملون المسؤولية عن
بؤسهم الاقتصادي عندما كان سوء الإدارة من قبل
قيادتهم ، واتهموا
الغرباء بالثورات التي حدثت في عام 2009
بعد أن زور النظام الإيراني
الانتخابات للسماح لعملاق المدينة المنورة بالحصول على
فترة ولاية ثانية ، واتهموا الآخرين بكل
المشاكل الأخرى مع  في حين
أن الإيرانيين هم في الحقيقة هم من يتدخلون
في شؤون الدول الأخرى وإيرا  ن
هي أكبر راع للإرهاب في العالم ،
يدعي كلاكما أنه يريد
محاربة الإرهاب.
الصعوبات في اليمن سواء كانت
القاعدة حتى إن الإيرانيين هم الذين
اغتالوا دبلوماسيين يهاجمون السفارات
ويفجرون حافلات ويفجرون معابد يهودية
هم الذين يرتكبون جرائم قتل في أوروبا
هم الذين اغتالوا
دبلوماسيين ولذلك فهم ليسوا من أجل
يبدو أن تعاون الإيرانيين في مكافحة الإرهاب أمر غريب جدًا
بالطبع سيقولون إنهم كانوا
يقاتلون داعش ، ولولا
الإيرانيين لكانت بغداد تديرها داعش
، ومن الواضح جدًا أن كلاكما
لديهما مشكلة كبيرة تتعلق بهما في دمشق.  كل داعش التي
أتحدث عنها نعم مع كل الاحترام الواجب
، كان الإيرانيون هم الذين سمحوا لداعش
بالازدهار في سوريا من خلال عدم
مهاجمتهم وبامتلاكهم  الميليشيات التي أتوا بها
إلى سوريا والمصدر المستقيل يهاجمون
المعارضة المعتدلة التي
أعطوها للإيرانيين
مجالاً للمناورة وحتى أنهم سمحوا
للنظام والآخرين بتبادل النفط وشراء
النفط من داعش ، وهذا ما سمح لداعش
بالنمو في سوريا.